The joe rogan experience.
And there's a,
there's other ones too.
There's,
there's other like crazy,
uh,
giant Lizard fucking things that,
that exist in like Bali and Indonesia and like in the,
like there's,
there's like monitors like crocodile monitors.
He ever seen those fucking things I haven't said,
hey,
they get fucking big,
they don't even know how big they get because they set traps for one.
I watched this one documentary where they set a trap for one and it was so big
it destroyed their trap.
So like what are those?
No idea how big this thing is.
Cause there's the stories that they get as big as crocodiles.
So what are those fucking things?
They
don't go there.
Fucking frock and I monitor jacks.
You,
whew.
Could you imagine just even fighting a 20 pound lizard that wanted to kill you?
Just a 20 pound fucked up lizard with big teeth that was just going after you
would terrifying.
Now imagine that 300 pound lizard,
that's like 600 pound lizard as like a nightmare.
I mean,
how big are fucking crocodiles?
Jesus fucking Christ.
That's one of those bad trip nightmares right there.
That's when you took too much,
too many mushrooms.
We had an episode of fear factor.
What we did something with little little baby alligators.
They're a little tiny,
tiny little alligators,
but it was a trip because we,
you know,
we had a bunch of them and I was watching him like fuck around in this tank and
swim or around next to each other.
I'm like,
what a crazy life form.
Crazy,
right.
It really was like watching like Ridley Scott Alien,
you know,
it was like,
look at this.
This is like an alien.
This is like a crazy little swimming,
little snapping ala cause I can get like right up next to it and snap the fuck
out of you.
If it got a hold of you,
I'll kill you.
He would love to kill you.
That little guy would love to kill you.
It's a little tiny thing and be like,
Ooh,
if I could kill you,
that would be awesome.
Something that small right,
right away wants to kill you.
Fuck you.
Little Baby Crocodile.
Fuck you want that baby crocodile will make a belt out of him.
You ever seen?
There's a video of one dude who likes swims with a crocodile.
It's like,
apparently though it's,
it's a Costa Rican crocodile and the the,
the crocodiles in Costa Rica,
like for some reason more calm,
Brian Cowen,
my friend Brian,
they don't necessarily snap on you right away and they're like kinda chill.
So this kind of like swims with this crocodile,
like gets in the water,
rolls around with it and shit and plays with it.
And you're like,
what am I watching?
Like it's his fucking dog.
My dog.
A fucking dog.
This is my water dog right here.
Like,
why are you doing that?
You crazy asshole,
man.
That's one of those guys where you hear about him on youtube later.
Oh for sure.
And like the hippo,
Gosh,
you remember the hippo guy?
There's a South American or South African guy who had a hippo.
He would ride it and he would,
they would take video of him riding his fucking hippo.
Yay.
Here we go.
My wait.
The hippo is the guy.
This is the crocodile.
The dude plays with,
look at this crazy motherfucker.
Look at him.
He's petting it.
Got Damn.
That thinks terrifying.
Looking.
Look at this.
Let's do it as getting in the water right now.
The,
the cross sale just rolls over on its back and he rubs its belly.
This is insanity.
Crazy.
Fuck.
This is insanity.
This is the lack of mega dog.
Yeah.
This dude is just hanging on to this crocodile riding with it.
Jesus.
Fuck.
Yeah.
He's crazy.
I'm way too high.
Way Too high to be watching
that crocodiles like this is my home.
He don't fuck with them.
Fucking crazy.
Do you have asshole?
You got to us crazy.
Oh,
dinosaur with a brain.
The size of a peanut.
A peanut.
That's crazy,
man.
How big is their brains?
It's like nonsense.
They're not that big.
It's like a nut.
Like a walnut,
right?
Yeah.
So trading him.
I don't,
you know,
uh Oh.
How'd you don't train that thing?
Don't train.
That is,
wait until it fucking kills you.
One day it's going to decide to kill you.
You hopefully hypnotized this thing with this is going to wake up and go,
well,
I'm a crocodile.
Who is this asshole?
It's just,
especially as it gets old,
it gets old and mean.
The yard is bullshit.
I don't want to swim today,
bitch.
She don't want to sweat.
I'm not rolling around in my back.
Get off,
get off me,
bitch.
Get off me mother fucker.
I leg get off and the man,
that's not cool anymore.
Cut Off.
Be Not.
How do you want to get married?
I want to have pocket all babies.
He's okay for this crocodile.
He's suppressing them.
Shit.
Watch my TV.
You in this cage for your own good.
You're famous now.
That's the one crocodile.
Wait until another one comes up.
Streaming like,
who are you motherfuckers?
Snap,
snap,
crazy.
Let me show you what you're supposed to do to people.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
Okay.